all right so
i am greg hogan
i work on infrastructure here at comma
um
yeah let's see if i can figure out this
clicker we go
all right let me turn this a little bit
that's better
all right so who's excited to hear about
infrastructure
wow
i didn't think it'd be very many people
that's good
i guess that's a lot of pressure though
now if i feel like people expect a lot
or something all right anyway we'll see
what happens
um
so the goal comma is to solve
self-driving caller solve self-driving
cars
uh we're gonna do it with machine
learning
and
uh we're gonna need really good
infrastructure to be able to accomplish
this we gotta be able to iterate fast we
gotta be able to train models you know
with reasonable speed and so forth
so
at comma
we call
everything supporting our customer
facing applications and model training
infrastructure so that's hardware and
software we call it all infrastructure
so
what do we need uh well one thing we're
gonna need is data
and so luckily we have thousands of
users every day collecting data for us
and somehow we need to get this data to
train models
so
uh we have devices out in the field that
have this data
and they upload it to
a storage account in azure
that
data when it comes in we throw it into a
queue
and then it goes into
it it gets picked up from things get
picked up from that queue from virtual
machines that run in an auto scaling
group
and then we do some processing on it and
uh decide what's good for you know what
what data do we have where are we
getting that's good for training
and we save some metadata about it off
so we want to minimize the cost of
processing this data we get a lot of
data
and we don't want to spend a fortune
processing it
um so what do we do well these cloud
storage providers pretty much all of
them now have this great feature where
like they have all this spare capacity
and no one's using it so they have
something called spot instances or low
priority vms
and so you can use their infrastructure
that's kind of spare
for like 20
of the normal cost
so but what's the downside of this
infrastructure that's like super cheap
well they can pull these vms back
anytime they want when some other
customer says oh hey i would like a vm
of that size
well then they kick you off and they
give it to someone else
so
how do we manage this how do we keep our
processing costs low and keep our
latency low
because we need to get this data
processed so that we can give our users
access to it and we want to do it in a
timely manner
so what we do is we
spin up multiple
sizes of these scale sets
uh with different cpus different memory
configurations
and uh the probability of us losing any
one of these scale sets losing all the
vms and one of these scale sets is
independent of the other scale sets
that are the same size
so what's the probability of us losing
all of them well it's exponential as we
add another scale set of a different
size and another scale set of a
different size
so
so that's why this works
and it works really great
so now that we have all this data
we need to be able to use it for
different things like some different
applications that we have
um
the data isn't public but like the api
we use for our applications we made it
public so that people can get their own
data
so you can go to api.com.ai for example
and you can see the documentation so
that you can you know if you wanted to
build your own application on top of
your data
we also have some nice tools that have
been in some of the other presentations
cabana for example it uses that same
public api
uh connect or it was previously explorer
it also uses that same public api and
this gives you you know nice dash cam
type functionality for reviewing your
data
and another nice thing that we offer
people
is what we call an ssh proxy
so
we sell a dev kit
and uh
it'd be nice if you could you know ssh
into your device from anywhere if you're
doing like development type stuff
but normally like if your cell phone is
on a cell network mobile data
they block port 22
because there's actually been problems
where like people accidentally leave
port 22 open and then people can get
into devices because you know they did
shady like the same username and
password for every device or something
like that
so how do we get around this
so what we do is
the devices whenever they have an
internet connection
they open a websocket connection to a
server that we have
in azure
and then
when you want to connect to your device
what you can do is you can
ssh into the hostname ssh.com.ai
from your computer
and your username is your device id
and you have to present a public key
that you had previously already set up
on your device
so then what our proxy server here does
is it bring it looks at your connection
and it says oh you're trying to connect
to this device let me go ask that device
what public keys are allowed to connect
to it
it pulls those public keys it then sees
if you can successfully authenticate
against the proxy server with that
public key
and then if you can then it lets you
tunnel an ssh connection
through the proxy server through the
websocket into your device
and then the device just i mean it's
literally port 22. like then your your
device then is going to authenticate
again with that same public key um this
is like what they call like an ssh jump
server we just tunnel it through a
websocket so that everything's making
incoming connections and it doesn't
matter if you're on a mobile network
with your device where port 22 is
blocked
so
in case anyone's wondering comma doesn't
have ssh access to anyone's device
uh ssh is off by default on your device
you have to turn it on and then you have
to set up you know what public keys you
want to have access to your device
and all the authentication you know
happens on the device we can't it's you
know the way public key authentication
works is you know even though the
traffic is passing through our proxy
server it's still encrypted with your
keys and so we have no way to be able to
look at any of that data
so all of that
infrastructure we just talked about
uh it's hosted in the cloud and it's
hosted there because you know the cloud
has these great features and we're
willing to pay a premium for high
reliability scalability and availability
all right so we got a little side track
there we're talking about you know
training models uh
but we needed some good stuff to uh we
needed a good pipeline of data coming in
and and you know that's kind of all the
stuff that supports that
so let's get back to let's get back to
training models so
what kind of hardware do we want to
train models
do we want to run it in the cloud
well
the most important thing to us is that
we maximize the compute we get per
dollar we spend
on that infrastructure
and
we can tolerate some failures the cloud
is great you know because it's so
scalable and reliable
but for research
you know we don't really need
all of that there's a lot of data that
we can like regenerate if we if we
needed to and so forth
um so what meets these requirements
so it turns out that refurbished
equipment running in a garage
actually is it's really cheap and it
works really well
so
if you consider the cost
of just the cloud data storage
for
all the data that we hold for for doing
model training
the cost of that cloud storage that we
would need to have equivalency
uh we would recoup all of our costs
in 10 months
buying all the hardware that we've
bought
so like our our return is so is so good
like
this here is a dgx super pod this
thing's brand new probably looks super
clean and nice so let's let's see if our
servers look like that
okay
so we started an office in san francisco
and at some point someone bought a rack
and put some servers in it
and then that rack turned into two and
then it turned into three
and
the power wasn't very stable in the
house at this point we had like a lot of
voltage swinging going on
when like gpus would hit really hard
model training
or you know running the segnet or
something and
so we need a lot of power conditioners
so you can kind of see here our ratio of
you actually can't see
the gpu servers here but you can see our
kind of ratio of power conditioners to
actual you know use of compute it's kind
of it's kind of high
another funny story so we actually uh
when we were in this house
something kind of weird happened
we had like a water leak at some point
and so they were in the front yard
digging up the water line and all of a
sudden like the two phases on the house
one went up to like
300 volts and the other went down to
like 100 volt 100 volts and we're like
what the what in the world is going on
uh and so
all of a sudden it went away and it kind
of correlated to when they buried this
this water line this copper water line
that was going into the ground again and
so
i take a clamp on amp meter and i'm
going around the house i'm trying to
figure out you know what the heck is
going on
and i clamped this clamp on amp meter
onto this copper pipe going into the
ground
it read 30 amps
30 amps of power getting dumped
into the ground through the copper pipe
so why is this happening well
it turns out that on the pole not even
in the house the pole where the house
gets power
the uh
the neutral
was completely disconnected like
corrosion
had
completely electrically disconnected the
neutral so when you have an imbalance in
between your two phases where's the
difference go it goes through the
neutral back to the transformer well we
had no neutral so what's the next best
thing well it might have actually been
the copper water pipes which the ground
is is clamped to
through the ground to the neighbor's
house which also has the neutral clamped
or the ground clamped onto the copper
wire and you know in your panels the
neutral and the ground are bonded
together in your main panel so that's
why we had 30 amps of power going down
into the ground
so
uh
so that was pretty funny
uh you know i don't know how gosh i
remember just like scratching my head
for days like really frustrated like
what the hell we got these nice power
conditioners and all this weird stuff's
going on but anyway
it's good good story i'm glad we glad we
figured it out
[Music]
so
right now we're running these servers in
this garage in the basement
and
eventually
the garage that the servers are running
in well the garage doesn't have enough
power anymore to power these servers so
we need to find power somewhere else
so
what do we do well there's more circuits
in the basement so we start pulling
power from other circuits
but eventually
the
the bottom floor of the house
doesn't have enough power
so
well
kitchens have a lot of circuits
a lot of 20 amp circuits
so
you can kind of see here there's a
there's a black thing going down from
that window to the garage
that's a bundle of really heavy-duty
extension cords
uh
powering some of our servers in the
garage
uh we also had a bunch of 3d printers in
there too so that didn't that didn't
help those things the the heated beds
can obviously draw quite a bit of
current too
uh but so you know
this can't go on forever
the house wasn't gonna have enough power
we really wanted to buy more servers
like we always want to buy more servers
[Music]
and so
we get a real office we moved to san
diego we got a big garage
we got three phase power
everything's great
well
when you're using 60 kilowatts of power
you're generating a crap ton of heat
and you got to get rid of that heat
somehow
so there's a few ways you can do this
you know the obvious one is if you run a
data center you have like climate
control right you got hvac well air
conditioning
is really expensive if you want to you
know get rid of 60 kilowatts of heat so
you know what do we do
well we're in san diego the temperature
doesn't swing that much right it doesn't
get super hot here
so we put in two 10 000 cfm two ten
thousand cfm fans we got an intake fan
and exhaust fan put in a partition for
separating the hot and cold aisle of the
servers
uh and
you know that that worked pretty
well but then we had another problem
uh
so
it turns out
that uh we started seeing signs of
corrosion like this fried capacitor this
is a backplane on the server so there's
a lot of dirt here
and we've got this capacitor that's
fried
so
what's going on here it turns out
there's this thing called equilibrium
moisture content or emc
and it's really important so
it's basically so equilibrium moisture
content
is the amount of moisture that a
material will hold and it's neither
releasing moisture into the air or
sucking moisture out of the air so like
there's no such thing as dry or wet
there's there's a continuous scale
and depending on what the relative
humidity and the temperature together
are determines what this equilibrium
moisture content is
uh so you gotta manage this or else uh
you know all that dirt from this dirty
garage
you know it's it holds moisture and
that's that was kind of a problem
so you to manage this basically uh you
can look around and like find numbers
uh you want to keep it below this 10.5
number generally if you go above that
it's considered corrosion or it's
considered a corrosive environment if
you keep it below you're in good shape
um so how do we stop this corrosion
um so it's the scale right where like as
the relative humidity goes up the
temperature goes down
the uh
the emc goes up
so
how do we keep the relative
humidity down
and the temperature up is the question
or
how do we how do we keep this number low
and so you know
the the obvious solution here is again
air conditioning
but
that's kind of expensive do we really
want to do that
no we don't there's a cheaper solution
so instead of sucking moisture out of
the air i'm sorry instead of lowering
the relative humidity by taking moisture
out of there with something like air
conditioning we can just raise the
temperature
so
when we buy these used servers they've
got like
metrics you know from whoever owned them
last so this here is a picture
of you can see the the black and gray on
the far left here
is what temperature the server was
running at before we got it and then
there's like a dead zone where it wasn't
on because no one owned it and then you
know the temperature after we start
running it so you know they ran it
around 21 to 23 c it sounds like a nice
life for a server
but then you know we get it and it runs
like 35 c to 42
so uh you know we our our goal is to
keep it under 43c 43c is
109.4 degrees fahrenheit
so you know we kind of we kind of abuse
them but everything in the server can
handle this like the the lowest
temperature i think of anything
like the lowest operating temperature of
anything in the server is probably the
spinning drives and the ones that have
spinning drives and that's like 55 c
so you know 43 is not that bad
so we also decided you know this is this
is a lot of dirt maybe we should try to
keep some of the dirt off the servers so
now we put this filter material just
right on the front of the servers
because you know to get a 10 000 cfm fan
with a filter on it is like
10 grand or something crazy so that
seems stupid we've got all these servers
they've got all these fans in them the
only place they take in air is right on
the front of them so we just throw the
media filter right on the front of it
we also decided you know we want these
back planes to last a while they're
still going to get dirty and this this
isn't going to filter out all the dirt
this garage just you know pretty dirty
so we put like 10 layers of conformal
coating on our backplanes and we use
like a potting compound to uh seal up
these exposed leads on these drive
connectors this is there's a picture of
a back plane that's been all sealed up
so that you know we don't have this uh
corrosion problem and this is really
only a problem in the front of the
server because
the temperature needs to be kind of low
for the emc
number to be high so in the back of the
server it's always really hot but in the
front of the server that's where you're
going to have problems and so you know
that's kind of what we saw the back
planes you know catch a lot of dirt and
it's the coolest part of the server
generally
all right
so what do we have in these racks
we've got
1888 cpu cores
72 gpus two petabytes of spinning drives
and
516 terabytes of solid state drives
we've got basically two classes of
servers we have servers that we use as
compute nodes and we have servers that
we use as trainers
so here's what our compute nodes look
like this is a rack of them
every one of these servers has 10
spinning drives they're 1u servers they
were new back in like 2015 or 2016.
but they were great we have three racks
of these
here's what our trainers look like
they're also old servers uh basically
you know lots of ram lots of gpus and
lots of network bandwidth
we also buy used networking
equipment
so
it's it's it boggles my mind how cheap
you can buy this stuff
uh
this is a 100 port that you're looking
at here this picture 100 port 64 or i'm
sorry 100 gigabit
64 port switch
this switch costs us 2
800
that's 6.4 terabit of switching capacity
and i remember at one point i bought a
new
netgear 48 port switch for comma
and that netgear switch was only 10
gigabit 48 ports it was almost 4 000
and i can get a 64 port 100 gigabit
switch
for
2.8 000 or yeah 2 800 so we have
multiple of these
uh and then we also have an infiniband
switch for the for the trainers to get
even higher network bandwidth between
them
so how do we use this hardware to train
models
uh well we've got all this data and now
we need really high bandwidth high
performance file system for the
different servers doing the different
tasks to pull the data
and work with it so originally we used
nfs for a long time
and yeah that doesn't scale
it's pretty bad so we looked around at
distributed file systems that existed
and everything was way more complicated
than what we needed
um
it's crazy how like complicated like
ceph is and all these things so we built
this this uh we built this distributed
file system called mini key value uh
it's open source it's on github it's
less than a thousand lines of code
uh it has an http interface you know
kind of like s3
and
the one of the reasons it's it's such a
small amount of code is because we use
nginx for the volume servers to serve up
the files so
so how so let's take a look at this this
is kind of a
a picture of kind of like our
infrastructure in our garage
and uh let's see how for example you
write data into mini key
value so the first thing that happens is
the client trying to write a file into
the into mini key value makes a put
request
to the mini key value master
the mini key value master then takes
that and
depending on how many replicas you want
it then makes that many copies
across that many machines so each of
these machines are called we call them
volume servers so there's the master
handling the requests initially and then
there's volume servers that hold the
data
so these are our machines with you know
10 spinning disks each and basically if
you have uh three copies of your data
it's going to put a copy on each of the
uh on each of the servers so um if
you've got three copies then you know
you can lose like one or two entire
machines and you haven't actually lost
any data
um
so that's what we use for our raw
driving data
we use three copies and so that's how
you put data into any key value uh the
the volume servers again are nginx so
basically it's just using you know
http requests passed through to nginx to
uh write out these copies of the data
so now how do we read data back out of
any key value say you want to say you
want to pull a file and you want to like
run through the video or something like
that
so the first thing that happens is the
client again makes a get request it hits
the master
the master then looks at the it looks at
the list of it maintains an index of the
list of volume servers that have the
data that it that you're trying to
request and then picks one randomly and
it returns a 302 redirect to you
so then what does the client do it just
follows that redirect
which you know hits an nginx server
directly that is hosting the files and
just returns it and so uh our master is
really simple like our master is just a
level db index of all the files on all
the servers the files on the servers are
actual like physical files and they have
a name that is the hashed key or the
base64 encoded key so like if our master
ever disappeared for like if our master
ever failed for some reason and we lost
our we lost our index we can actually
regenerate the data that was in the
master very easily just by spinning
through all the files
on base64 encoding them and repopulating
that that master index
all right
so now that we have a high
uh a high performance distributed file
system um let's let's run some tasks
that are going to
generate our ground truth
uh for training models
so
the way that this works is um a
workstation uh we have some software
libraries custom built that we have that
we use for submitting jobs to our to all
of our servers
and
basically it builds up a list of tasks
uh each task can run independently in
parallel of all the others and it kind
of manages it manages dependencies and
gets results and so forth and submits
them as as uh
as they can be submitted
so then all of these
these three racks of compute nodes that
we have they're all pulling tasks out of
out of consumers
and
they then
read data from our spinning drive mini
key value we have a mini key value
instance that's just spinning drives
they then you know to run tasks they
need to read data from you know like
let's say the raw driving data that we
have
and then they write the results back out
to the mini key value instance that is
solid state drives so that way like our
model trainers have like really high iop
really high bandwidth
uh
file system that they can pull uh the
data from for training
so
let's see here and go back one
there we go
so our spinning drive right here
um
it's 40 machines
it has 400 spinning drives spread across
40 servers and so that's our two
petabytes of storage that we have
which is about 10 million minutes of
driving data
and then our
our mini key value solid state drive
or mini key value that's you know all
solid state drives is 20 machines
and that's our 516
terabytes of ssd
all right so now we've got our ground
truth generated um
let's train a model so how does that
work
so we have 10 servers here that are
model trainers
um
we can run a lot we have 10 of them so
we can run a lot of experiments in
parallel each of these model trainers
has a 100 gigabit
ethernet uh
network connection to one of those
hundred gigabit switches
and then one of our racks has another
400 gigabit per server hooked into an
infiniband switch so we can do things
like rdma
and do like parallel uh training and so
forth let's see i went too far
okay so
when we kick off uh model training
uh
it's it's something that's running on
one of the gpu servers
this is our mini key value ssd instance
then you know it pulls data from
pulls data from there each of those
machines has 20 gigabit of network
connectivity so it's really high
bandwidth um
and then
each epoch
it uh
generates some metadata
and it writes it out to
what we call our our reporter server
which i'll talk about in a minute
so
you repeat this you repeat this about a
thousand times
and then we've trained a model
so this is our reporter server this is
what it looks like
um
one of the screens in our report server
uh it's kind of like
it's kind of like tensorboard um it has
a lot of charts and images
uh it's pretty simple
something we custom built just to hold
all of our experiments
um we looked around kind of at like the
other options that were open source and
available and free and
they didn't really have all the features
we wanted
[Music]
so that's why we ended up building
something custom
and it really wasn't like this wasn't a
big project at all
um another another screenshot from our
model reporter this is
um
this is uh example of like where you can
pull up worst losses
for an epoch
and so that's pretty much all the
infrastructure that we have that we use
for uh
training our models
um so
our user base grows like 50 every six
months at least on average
um
we we need to scale up a lot of our
infrastructure as we you know doesn't
take us too long to grow another 10x at
that rate
so we've got a lot of work to do you
know there's always ongoing work to
really scale things up
um
we want to build a 10x larger data
center
so we've got all kinds of
exciting things we would love to do to
uh
you know uh
train on
maybe 10 million segments uh of driving
data
and running the ground truth for that
takes a long time would take a long time
on our on our current setup um
so
um
let's see
so yeah if you uh
i don't know do you think this stuff is
exciting to you you think uh
uh you think that's cool stuff uh we're
hiring and so
uh it looks like i'm
pretty much out of time here but uh
yeah i'll be around and
find me if you have any questions
[Applause]
oh hang on
if we have
oh i thought i was gonna be really cool
and i didn't get any questions like like
does steve jobs take questions after he
like talks
i don't think he does does he
go ahead
uh okay
hi i'm in the back on the first floor
hello i i can't see anyone
what's up oh hey
all right thank you for the mini key
value presentation was very interesting
um
i i okay maybe i maybe there's not a
good answer for this but like how did
that not exist like there must be like
other companies trying to build their
own training pipelines in their own data
centers
yeah i mean it's it's pretty it's pretty
the functionality is pretty limited
right like a lot of people want you know
like super high availability
and uh uh you know more
a lot a lot of you know kind of better
assurances than what we have we've got
mini key value has this kind of
bottleneck for writing data which is the
master we've got a i've got ideas how we
can improve that like
we've got some pretty specific
how do i say this we don't need a lot of
these crazy features that these other
distributed file systems have so like
for example
our data our mini key value instance
that has three copies of the data
uh this master is a bottleneck all the
writing goes through the master right
now it manages getting three copies out
to three the volume servers so like that
can obviously be a bottleneck right
so other distributed file systems
they're like oh well that's that's never
going to work right but for us it
actually does because
the amount of data we take in like we
take we we don't if we could generate
like we have a thousand users if we
could generate 10 times as much data
today
would that actually be good data for us
the answer is no unless we have 10x more
users too like we need diversity in our
data so
our data comes in slowly
and we don't need a ton of bandwidth to
this uh mini key value instance that has
a bunch of redundancy
but on the other hand
we do need really high rate performance
for our mini key value solid state
instance right because that's where our
our reporters read data and write
well we need to be able to like
massively write out our grant our ground
truth from all of our from all of our
consumers and so
uh there's a solution to this because
there's a good solution to this because
we don't need multiple copies of that
data we only need one copy
because if we ever lose a drive
that's like a small portion of our data
number one like we don't really care but
number two if we did care we can just
rerun the ground truth and regenerate it
if we have a disc failed like who cares
we'll replace it we'll re-run ground you
know the ground truth for that so what
we can do
is we can actually use redirects to
write data
uh if all the master is doing is doing
redirects like it's it's you know we
don't have any performance problems um
so when you only have one copy of your
data like our mini key value ssd
instance
your writing can be redirects too you
don't have to funnel all your data
through through the master we could also
do like crazy stuff like have the client
write out multiple copies but like again
like you know when
when it's uh when you're really focused
when you understand your own problem
while you're really focused you can you
know come up sometimes with really
simple solutions to those things
thank you that gives me a lot of insight
yeah no problem
you mentioned the humidity
is a problem in san diego it's about 60
on average in in would it be beneficial
to move
the
compute cluster to somewhere like 29
palms where the humidity is half
uh i don't know like why do i care if i
run my servers at 43c
do servers have i don't know does anyone
like advocate advocating for server
rights like do they do they get like is
there is it what is it like uh
child uh
whatever you know like children can't
work in like hot conditions
we're gonna have that for servers
someday too
yeah i don't know
yeah i mean
it would we wouldn't have had this
problem that would be nice but
uh it's kind of like you know it doesn't
really matter
um what's been your
largest challenge in terms of growth and
scalability of this hybrid cloud
environment and then also a second
question is why did you decide azure
when there's more mature cloud
environments out there like aws oh okay
uh
yeah
okay i got answers for those things so
the biggest challenge i think in scaling
any of this stuff
is like finding simple ways to do it
that doesn't require us to hire like a
team of people to manage it right like
like why do we care that mini key value
is under a thousand lines of code we
care because like
george wrote it i can sit down and look
at it and like fix bugs in you know
sometimes a matter of minutes
and and and you know i can i can i can
read the whole code base in like an hour
right and understand everything that's
going on
and so
uh
you know finding good solutions to these
problems is
is uh
uh you know less code is always better
and
i think a good example is
we used to spend a lot of money
processing transcoding video processing
video files as they were uploaded to us
and
you know we were doing this and i'm
always trying to figure out how do we
lower our cloud spending and i'm like
well this is obvious like it should
happen on the device
why are we transcoding in the cloud so
you know that's what we did we didn't
like build some crazy stuff to like do
caching and be smart about oh someone
requested the first video of this file
let's start transcoding it and then the
second and the third and the fourth one
minute segment you know you could go
really complicated and build something
that probably works
really well but you know
finding a simple
you know that's that's like writing a
lot more software and and you know
scaling that thing sounds like a
nightmare and you know it's still
probably kind of crappy
so you know it's that you know that's
the real that's the real challenge i
think you know finding a way to do it
really cost effective second question
you asked so why are we in azure so we
uh
we weren't always in azure i don't think
i've ever really told anyone this story
so before i started at comma everything
was in aws and why were we in aws well
the reason we were in aws was because
if you run a startup
these cloud providers they'll give you
they'll give you so much money
yeah and why do they give you all that
money well they give you all that money
because
you know
uh if you
if you build this really expensive
system with all that those free credits
that they give you well you got to keep
paying for it when the credits run out
you know even if they give you hundreds
of thousands of dollars it comes with an
expiration also so if you don't spend it
really fast it's like they incentivize
you to spend the money really fast
because it expires and then
once it expires
well how much is your cloud bill every
month now and you got to start paying
that
so we got i don't even know how much
money we got from aws
that money ran out so we shopped around
we said
who else will give us free money
so number two was azure
and i want to say they gave us
360 thousand dollars
of credits
that was also a little bit before i
started and after i started
um
after i started um
i needed to transfer this subscription
to my email address i'm like this will
just be so much easier so i'm going to
do it well it turns out azure is
ridiculous you have to
like they can't transfer a subscription
they have to cancel your sponsorship
with all these credits
and then they have to set up a new
sponsorship with the new email address
so
guess what happened when they set up the
new sponsorship after we spent most of
our money
we started back over
at 360 thousand dollars
i didn't complain actually there's a
little more to the story than that
actually what happened was
they
so they train they did it and we didn't
have enough money i'm like what the heck
you guys are screwing us over they're
like oh no oh no we'll fix that yeah
they fixed it
so
anyway that's why we're in azure so we
we didn't we like like now we're you
know we're trying to we're trying to run
our infrastructure in a way that's you
know maintainable and so you know we
just now we're just decreasing our costs
um
[Laughter]
hi um
uh awesome presentation uh really love
your passion about the subject uh
question um
what about like backup and what what is
like your dr plan
do you have one
uh for what right like for
for
the data that we use for training
uh
there is no the the disaster recovery is
bottlenecked by how fast we we're like
worst case it's bottlenecked by how fast
can we collect new data from our users
right
so
uh we back up some data like like our
reporter server we send it you know to
like cold storage or whatever
inexpensive storage and azure you know
we run on-prem the reporter just like
the the trainers and everything
uh in the cloud you know it's just kind
of the same thing we
uh
one of the first things i worked on was
you know really making everything
infrastructure is code deploying things
in an automated way
uh so you know a lot of our disaster
recovery from like an infrastructure
perspective not from a data perspective
is uh you just redeploy history deploy
things and you know i'm huge on putting
everything in scale sets you know so
like your recovery is built in right
like every time you scale up you're
practicing your recovery which is great
thank you yeah
so you mentioned um
the like spot instances and stuff and
kind of balancing between
instances of different sizes can you
talk a bit about how like
generally particular workloads fit
within particular instance sizes i don't
really know what your compute needs are
but how how do you balance that out if
you have like uh
a certain memory compute sort of ratios
that you're trying to maintain yeah so
uh one of my goals at one point when i
was one of my first goals at comma was
to
get our processing time like the latency
from when we receive a file from a user
to when it's available in like explorer
connect cabana to be under 10 minutes on
average for like 99.9 of our data or
something like that over the over the
like over the course of a month
so i worked really hard on that
and i'm happy to say that our data now
uh is processed like on average under 10
seconds after we receive it
um
and
so
we used to do like heavier stuff like
like processing video files and so forth
so you know a lot of the solution to
this was was eliminating that stuff
pushing it you know pushing someone back
to the device
uh using the q logs for every like
really pushing people hard to use our q
logs for you know our processing needs
um
for customer facing stuff uh you know
like figuring out what data we can train
on
i always you know tell people it has to
be based on the cue logs because you
know we don't want to pull the
the raw log files to to figure that
stuff out
um
so we need
the long they're the short of this long
story is basically we need very small
vms
we we spin up the smallest possible vms
which helps right because
uh
when when when we're out bid
uh and we lose instances we lose these
spot instances the more cores we're
using the more likely it is that someone
is going to steal our vm like say you
know say we use four core machines
versus two core machines well if someone
needs a two core machine there's only
four cores
well then we're gonna lose the four core
machine but if we're doing two two core
machines and someone needs two cores you
know we only lose one of them so we use
we use like the smallest but i i pick
the i picked the least expensive
um you know the least expensive skus
uh and
um
always do like the
azure has this great thing where you can
run the operating system out of the
super fast cache so then the vms come up
like super they you know they we scale
up and down really fast um so yeah we
just use we use the tiny instances
and um
yeah that's all we need because we we
really squeeze down the processing as
much as possible
obviously there's very little processing
happening if every file we process is
done in 10 seconds
got any more questions
nice hat
thank you
a quick question about infrastructure as
code do you guys use like a terraform or
ansible or what does that tech stack
look like yeah we use terraform
uh
like in my previous job
things were also in azure and we used to
use the like the arm templates i think
those are great too but i mean if it's
not broke you don't you don't change it
right we just always use terraform and
it works great
yeah we uh so we use terraform and then
i guess you were asking like ansible so
we use terraform and then i like really
try to use uh
cloud in it to bring up the vms
basically
i try to keep those vms as simple as
possible so
most of our vms that run in the cloud
it's a cloud it's uh it uses cloud in it
to
install the azure cli so that it can do
like integrated authentication to do
things like pull keys for storage
accounts that have been given like
role-based access so we need the azure
cli so that the vms have access to
things
and then and then docker
so everything that we run runs in a
docker container so we just need to
basically uh install docker in the azure
cli
hey
um so i guess i sort of wonder in the
long run um
how much data do you guys keep like i
guess it sounded like you weren't
particularly concerned if there was a
case where you have like some video or
other piece of data you want to train on
and it gets lost because i guess one you
can get it back but like do you guys
store all the video you've ever
collected from customers or do you clean
it up as time goes along and you like
upgrade the cameras and becomes less
useful etc uh we we don't store all the
data that's ever been uploaded to us we
retain the
um we retain retain the raw data that we
get for only 14 days
um because
like the data i mean again like keeping
our cloud bill low
like i mentioned at the beginning the
storage is so expensive
like that's how they get you and you
really can't separate
things from the storage very well like
who has crazy high bandwidth for free to
you know cloud providers and then they
charge you if you want to pull data out
of the cloud outrageous rates like eight
cents per gigabyte so uh you know if
they if they get you hooked into that
storage
they really got you hooked
uh and so
uh yeah so we we just keep the data for
14 days uh because otherwise
we'd be you know even now even keeping
the data for only 14 days our storage is
by far our biggest cloud expense
and then the lower quality stuff we keep
for at least a year so like if you have
prime you can you can watch your low
quality video
uh in like connect should be able to
back a whole year
great thank you so much greg
you